I think this is a really great story an
Indian girl by the name of Cheri as' Rao
uploaded a video on a plane after she
had been harassed by a man and well take
a look in the will discussion you're
asking for forgiveness why because I'm a
girl and you have the right to touch me
anytime I need her anywhere you want to
what forgiveness are you asking for did
you do it only once by was it by mistake
I will call the security I will make
sure I make a complaint bye bye please I
am sorry please I'm sorry that I'm a
girl
please forgive me so you want to say
that you want to give me a written
apology for misbehaving with me why did
you do that what did you think I will
keep quiet you think this is a mistake
so things like murder
these things are mistake you decided to
action I will decide the reaction okay
so I love that line you decided the
action I'll decide the reaction is
really fantastic I love that she
empowered herself with this apparently
they were sitting next to each other and
I guess he was like grabbing her leg or
something in the description of the
video it says that he's now in police
custody we can't independently verify
that but I think this is really really
great it's an example of how to use the
internet properly how for girls and
women to get the power back I have a
feeling that you're both pretty much
agree with me on that
Jacqueline yeah I mean I'm just kind of
shocked that this guy touches her out in
the open and he must have done it
expecting not to have anything negative
happened to him yeah otherwise he would
have done something so blatantly wrong
you know he did more than once by the
right more than once he did it twice and
assume that he would get away with it
and then when she was sitting there
yelling at him calling him out he look
around there's people just standing
there doing absolutely nothing and you
can hear the flight attendant like
baggage claim information is here yeah
no one reacts to it at all like it's
just like well yeah he's a man he gets
to do that sometimes yeah so there's a
couple things here so there's the
cultural part of this but let's just
focus on the YouTube four part first the
YouTube before
let's put focus on
two parts you like YouTube Bart smart
videos do really well on YouTube but the
YouTube part of it I think is great like
do you are you down with that the idea
this public shaming thing because I
think sometimes it can be bad but I
think in this case this was this was
pretty awesome I love this girl this
video was so awkward to watch yeah and
it was so empowering I think she rocks
and um I like that he keeps saying I
made a mistake I made a mistake like
he's like I made a mistake and I got
caught like yeah that's what he feels
shame about is that he got caught and
maybe he won't do it again but that's
the only thing he's sorry for he's like
bummer I didn't realize you had a video
camera yeah when I tried to I think he
tried to feel her through the back like
he was rubbing her leg or something
gross right so what do you think these
guys now again I get the cultural
differences in every country is
different and within countries they're a
different cultural from north to south
and all that but how do we how do we as
Americans discuss a video like that
without pushing our values on them as
everyone always says you Americans want
to push your values on every I mean for
women's rights that's what is pushing my
values means you know promoting women's
rights then hell yeah I want to push my
values yeah I mean it's just amazing to
me that he thought he could get away
with something so horribly wrong I mean
it just I feel bad for her that women
are so disrespected that she has to do
this she has to make a big statement she
has to publicly shame him for anyone to
care yeah are you guys consistently
amazed at women's rights in 2015 like
there's still so much stuff that we hear
constantly right now people are talking
about the Saudi Arabia thing because the
King died and that women could not drive
even if they were allowed to go to his
funeral
they couldn't drive there themselves I
tweeted something about it and then
people were yelling at me that people
from Saudi Arabia
we're telling me no no we actually
respect women so much that's why we
don't let them drive we're like their
chauffeurs I can't even imagine it's
like we just like to keep them in cages
there are their little dolls that we
like to you know look at ana door and
not just treat as a human being with
respect and it yeah to your point of our
culture on this like let's reverse the
rules let's say it was a woman doing
that to a guy right I mean I'd feel the
same way like I mean I think you should
just stand up for yourself and on
that behavior it should be condoned
whether it's a male to a female er yeah
that's actually a great point so if you
were to reverse it do you think that
ever happens oh yeah that happens where
we're older I hear really of men getting
sexually harassed all the time really
and I feel bad because in the workplace
you know I hear about it all the time
and I feel bad because if they say
something they're like oh man you should
like it because it's a girl just coming
on to you you know why are you
complaining right you know like it's
something cool for them to go through
and I feel bad right you know it's this
it works both ways that's actually like
when you see these like hot female
teachers in their 20s that you know
molest a kid that's 14 or something
there's always this implicit thing in
the media like oh that lucky kid yeah
versus obviously when it happens with
the male teacher and a girl it somehow
seems work so I guess there's a lot of
doubles oh yeah it's also could be like
a cougar you know I mean like her
husband cougar like that guy would be
considered a husband cougar if he was a
girl right right
anyway don't harass women whether you
know them or not and know that we're all
online now so there's a good chance
someone like this great girl is gonna
call you out